all that stands between you and the net
are three defenders fueled up and ready
to land a napkin save your surroundings
are familiar teammates flanking you on
both sides
green grass below and of course of all
your job is simple get the ball in the
net at all costs
this isn't soccer though it's not even
cars playing soccer it's rocket cars
playing soccer and it's called rocket
and it's one of the most popular eSports
on the planet this is its story back in
2008 game developer psyonix released
supersonic acrobatic rocket powered
battle cars a physics based simulation
of real-life soccer where the players
were cars just like in soccer the cars
goal was to work together to manipulate
the ball pass it back and forth and land
it in the net as often as possible the
game is about as simple as it gets
three cars per team one ball five
minutes on the clock and the team with
the most goals when the buzzer sounds
wins instead of passing the ball
person-to-person it's bomb to car to car
and you're able to use your rocket boost
to manipulate the speed of your car and
partake
and some jaw-dropping acrobatics over
the line that ball should have blown up
on all your dirty the game was
originally released for the PlayStation
3 as a quick $15 download and was
received with mixed reviews the original
title was downloaded over 2 million
times by ps3 users
it's middling release results aside
there was a hungry competitive scene
that grew up around it competitive play
got popular enough that a third party
ranked latter even cropped up the skill
ceiling was incredibly high for such a
simple game and players were enamored
with harnessing their rocket cars taking
advantage of the terrain the rocket
boosts and capacity for high-level
teamwork in 2015 psionics tried it again
the exact same idea but this time the
sequel was called rocket and the game
exploded
psionics tried a different marketing
approach this time around using YouTube
and leveraging the popularity of twitch
streamers for sponsored content to draw
eyes towards the game they're just me
trying to stop any of those deer in the
hit me yep there's the bump attempt
rocket League has since tripled the
success of its predecessor selling over
6 million copies and attracting more
than 40 million players worldwide in
addition to your upfront purchase of
course the game features the ability to
customize your car with cosmetic add-ons
you can tinker with everything from the
paint on your car to decals and parts
and even the way the ball explodes when
you score and as the game has increased
in popularity there have been multiple
collaborations with various pop culture
I can auger fee
yes you can even play with the DeLorean
from Back to the Future hey Doc you
better back up we don't have enough road
to get up TV a rose well we're going we
don't need roads
[Music]
[Music]
what's unique about this game is its
simplicity unlike your standard title
rocket Li more or less starts and stops
with cars playing soccer enjoying the
game honing your skills and becoming
great are all completely reliant on the
games physics engine nothing more and
this isn't a downside on the contrary it
might be rocket leads single greatest
asset this game channel's the history of
human competition understanding it is as
simple as looking at the screen there
aren't pages of items or passive
abilities to worry about take a massive
game like League of Legends for example
during the 2018 LCS summer split one
single patch was able to turn the game
on its head and change the meta game
overnight which is exciting but can also
be overwhelming for non-committal fans
when the meta is always going to be put
the ball on the net being a fan comes at
a much lower cost because at the end of
the day it's just physics and it was
that ease of entry that attracted
players to hone their skills and master
the elegant format rocket league offered
which of course led to the next step
eSports the RACs is the biggest
tournament in rocket league history each
region EU and na had two independent
open qualifiers a whopping twenty
thousand four hundred seventy eight
players signed up in the first
qualifiers but only eight teams from
each region went onto the group stages
this is where the simplicity of the
design shows how much of an asset it is
although the game isn't being fine-tuned
all the time the community is always
able to push its limitless skill ceiling
players like squishy muffins and cuck
seer have been able to invent sealing
shots and pinch shots to completely warp
the way the game is played
shortly after the game's release another
community of hyper competitive players
featuring many of the same faces of the
original title followed and then came
the rocket League Championship Series in
2016 the top four teams of each region
has been determined and I am now going
to compete for that chance at the
remaining prize pool of $55,000 eSports
often come with growing pains games can
be hyper complicated at the top level
and it often takes years to acquire
enough endemic fans to really call the
journey into eSports successful this is
the heart of the success of rocket
League eSports even during its first
baby steps into competitive play in
season one fans loved watching the game
rocket leagues followers were dedicated
and passionate and growing quickly due
to the ease of entry the game offers
[Applause]
right there when you watch the our LCS
for the first time
it's about as jaw-dropping a jump from
casual to competitive you'll see across
all of eSports these guys are doing
backflips now this is more like golf
commentary I love it oh that's looking
good there we go Metsa executing
carefully-crafted game plans and passing
players back inside Union nice flame
looks for Jacob
using the walls and their boost tool and
incredible double tap goals Stephanie
but by himself he's gonna allow see but
significant self but he's gonna get a
double tap sidewall it really shows off
the skill intensive sealing that the
game has to offer the imaginative way
that the best players play is a sight to
see season one of the our LCS was all
about bye-bye power cosmic maybe the
most hyped up match so far today yeah I
mean it's the first time on the our LCS
stream that we're gonna get to see high
power cosmic and I guarantee you it will
not be the last just like everyone else
they started the season trying to figure
out their way around a brand new eSports
landscape but as the World Championship
approached they started to heat up the
past plays are incredible here Latino on
the wall putting up two gambit who puts
it over to chrono V look at that pass
off the gambit gambit plays it back over
off that wall everybody up in the air
and getting to it early and once they
settle then nobody could stop them and
they brought home the first place chunk
of the modest $55,000 prize pool it's on
the wall Cronulla beam
tries to put it over micros drops it
cooks our
I by power are the morals yes champion
[Laughter]
worlds was exciting and showed that this
little game that could had real eSports
potential ibuypower was the jumping off
point for rocket leagues eSports growth
they were very marketable world
champions and chrono V in particular did
a lot to grow the scene with his stream
oh my god after season 1 world's rocket
League eSports grew substantially and a
lot of that growth took place in Europe
which was quickly becoming the breeding
grounds for much of the young talent the
game had to offer
[Music]
[Music]
it was during season three that the
eSports community fell in love with
northern gaming they were the number
four seed out of Europe headed into the
World Championship but quickly became
the Cinderella story of the tournament
after being swept by NRG they were
knocked down to the loser's bracket
but in dramatic fashion they fought hard
to defeat the number two and a seed in
rogue to get to the finals a spot nobody
expected them to be in northern gaming
one of our dynasties here there were so
many question marks around them coming
into this land would they be able to
perform with the sub turbo pulse' and
they have done exactly that they would
then go on to be maakad not once but
twice to reset the bracket and become
the season 3 world champions and look at
these champions ladies and gentlemen
notably this was the coming-out party
for turbo pulse' one of the game's
brightest stars was born that day and as
we now know rocket league would never be
the same
turbo coming in as the substitute such a
huge deal really really devotion to
share that MVP award with turbo pulse'
yeah but it was season four that rocket
League found its most heroic team the
lineup of violent panda Kade off and the
apper mentioned turbo pulse' would go on
to define the eSport through their
dominance
[Applause]
simply put they were the best and their
success would not stop with season four
they would go on to win season five of
our LCS in Europe as well before the
roster was bought by Dignitas shortly
before the World Championship so the
poster get up high
and as they continue to win
rocket League eSports quickly became the
story of Dignitas see how they can
respond against this Dignitas squad but
they're threatening again that shot I
know it should go in so perfect
placement - nothing Dignitas fire since
the dig acquisition at the beginning of
2018 and team one virtual II everything
they placed first in the our LCS season
5 finals 1 Northern arena and dominated
our LCS season 6 Europe Remco comes back
up mitts and arses there in violet panda
shuts it down three seasons in a row
it's dignitas and along with the
dominance of this historic squad rocket
League eSports was growing in popularity
with every passing tournament we had a
buzzer beater in game 7 to send us the
overtime in game 7 can you believe it
there was no better gift for this
awesome crowd than that Sears the
greatest series we have ever seen in our
LCS history buoyed by the popularity of
Dignitas and their impressive run other
faces within the community continued the
trend of growing and helping to give
this rising scene the superstars it
deserved this includes players like
cloud nines squishy muffins a player who
is known for his raw mechanical skill
and highlight reel plays he'll spawn in
the back
you heard them on the desk talking about
a woman the fourth one not very often do
I genuinely have no clue it goes bad to
happen one on hurts with dg2 esports
rocket league lineup has also become a
fan favorite
chrono V Jane apps and Rizzo have become
widely loved for becoming one of the
most tight-knit teams in the world and
watching them play together is a
testament to the team game that rocket
League is at a competitive level early
on they were seen as a high prosser that
never really lived up but it was at
eleague that everything clicked for
these guys and the community fell in
love with them five four they play it
out turbo pulls up picks up he's got
pileup in it to work with but they have
to keep it in the air it doesn't happen
jeetu are the elite champions
crow Novi you are an Atlanta native
correct yeah right here how does it feel
to win it front in front of the literal
home crowd it feels good to finally
bring home a trophy for home and does
rocket League was reaching the peak of
its popularity the most memorable
tournament in the game's history went
down welcome back to the our LCS season
6 world championships I'm Lee Paxton I
gotta say I got goose bumps
gearing up for the 2018 World
Championship Dignitas was the absolute
odds on favorite to take down yet
another trophy it was almost a given in
the eyes of many of the game's most
dedicated fans and this time more than
any other they'd be getting paid the
event boasted a whopping 1 million
dollar prize pool but in Rocky League
anyone can win on any given day and what
transpired was arguably the greatest
upset of the year in eSports
ladies and gentlemen live from the
Orleans Arena right here in Las Vegas
this is the Grand Finals of the rocket
League World Championship cloud9 did be
impossible they worked their way through
the lower bracket winning five straight
series before getting their shot against
Dignitas
the streak is over cloud9 take the first
batch and the grand finals
they beat the game's best team on the
biggest stage to reset the bracket
before winning another full set to take
the entire tournament and make rocket
league history and they do it cloud 9
your season 6 world 2 bids
and while perhaps the most exciting
moment in the game's history went down
the events twitch viewership peaked at
more than 100,000 let's hear it for your
world champion skies cloud nine
[Applause]
in many ways this upset embodies rocket
leads potential as a nice warmth when a
game is based around a physics engine
like this you get that sports effect
that feeling that when pushed in the
right direction anyone can win on any
given day like a goalie having a huge
playoff run in hockey a closer that just
can't be solved in baseball or a
quarterback that just won't be beat in
football in rocket League it feels like
there's a capacity to will yourself cast
a skill disadvantage and this is what
creates fandom now there's still a trail
to be paved in order for rocket League
to jump into the upper echelon of
eSports
this isn't csgo League of Legends or
dota 2 where million-dollar purses and
full-time contracts are the norm but
clearly people are starting to take
notice and the game has not stopped
growing psionics has even taken the
interest in eSports as a means to add to
the game in 2018 they announced an
in-game tournament mode in conjunction
with steam our next update coming this
spring includes tournaments and all new
features that allows our players to
create and run their own tournaments and
games if these big events and large
prizes continue it's only a matter of
time until we see more of eSports as
largest organizations jumping into the
game the format has been so grossly
popular all along the spectrum of casual
to hardcore that psyonix has been able
to expand their engine to other sports
now there's a rocket car iteration of
hockey and basketball to pull you in
just like the games original form
[Music]
more than anything
rocket League has shown us the sheer
depth to which the eSports community can
take ahold of a game to be captured by
something so simple and wield it to show
just how skilled they can be it creates
moments like a squishy muffin ceiling
shot or Justin's late-game heroics to
force overtime in season five worlds
[Applause]
this is people making hundreds of
thousands of dollars competing in a game
where cars play soccer and it's so damn
cool this is the world we live in and
rocket league is only getting bigger
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]